cause when you do that thing right there
flipping your ear baby i swear come on
i don't think you know what you're doing
[Music]
i think my favorite part of the country
community is
just family first of all uh everybody
you know just being so kind and so nice
you know like me
morgan uh luke combs dana shea
you know everybody just good friends um
i play xbox
a lot of them all the time so it's just
yeah it's a good
good community to be in i think country
music is so
different from every other genre in its
own unique way and i think you know this
um i've never listened to
music that that just struck me
differently than country has
[Music]
[Music]
good
[Music]
[Applause]
still a little bit fleshy
[Applause]
i feel like once we kind of get past
this next phase of the pandemic whatever
it is
it's kind of like a powder keg waiting
to go off i mean people are ready to
like
country fans want to come to nashville
they want to go to the bars
they want to see each other congregate i
think you want to go to shows too so
definitely take a little bit of a hit
but it's it's going to come back i think
the the biggest way um to support
our small businesses and especially
these incredible venues that
are suffering right now is to win it
safe
[Applause]
[Music]
god
hollywood